hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the Watson Scott test I'm
not sure what's happening this test is
designed to help you understand your
deepest anxieties and the underlying
causes of your darkest fears for each
question select the response which gives
the best and most truthful answer at the
end of the examination you will receive
your Anil thesis and a certificate of
participation okay please note that
typically only 13% of participants are
able to complete the test due to me
onset of total body paralysis or
unanticipated cardiac arrest or
unanticipated bowel explosions do you
wish to continue oh yeah I like the
bowel explosion part make my entire and
Destin's douche out I'm a douche what
firstly some calibration questions how
many minutes are there in one hour oh I
know this one oh you think I don't know
this one oh you silly [ __ ] I am a smart
man I I dropped out of college if there
are three oranges and I take away two
how many are left
what depends on how much you put on the
right hmm i'ma go with one are you
playing a game right now I'm gonna go
with a whole lot of yeah I think I think
I'm doing a let's play and by definition
there's got to be a game hang on I don't
think this is spooky enough in here and
let's get this lets get maximum spook
going on
three two one spooked
our dog in here okay yes I'm gonna go
with yes I believe yes are you sure it's
a game yeah yeah I'm pretty sure cuz
libration complete your test will begin
now okay you got it I'm ready it's
raining outside and you're walking in
bare feets you take one step forward and
crush a snail between your toes
you feel felt disgusted Biff how why am
i walking outside in the rain in bare
feet and if I crush the snail between my
toes does that mean I picked it up with
my toes and squashed it between my toes
iOS's I'm gonna go disgusted there's a
knock at your door you open it to find
an old woman in tattered clothes huh she
says she's being chased and wants to
hide inside your home come on get her
inside come on down get her in your pet
cat drops a dead mouse on your front
doorstep I don't like this its front
legs missing yeah
but the mouse of the cat wait that the
mouse or the cat cuz if it's a cat I'm
kind of curious how it how it's is it
just standing up on his two legs I'd be
proud fight a cat that was missing its
front legs but standing tall and proud
and gets me that dead mouse I'm proud
I'm proud I will now show you an image
oh please don't I don't want this please
study it okay here I go
the image will not move oh I don't like
the fact that you had to preface it by
saying and what move there we go I'm
ready oh I don't like it I don't like
that here I my amp up the spook factor I
got a I got a candle here
really
get the candle fire going how'd that
manage make you feel ah I mean not any
of these I just didn't like it I'm gonna
go with call it anxious oh do you
believe in ghosts hmm nah I don't think
so
I'm good have you ever seen a ghost no
no no I haven't haven't seen one looking
around my room right now thinking about
the room oh no you're in right now oh
don't do that
has anyone ever died here well if you
count my career maybe you could call
that dying here but I not not yeah not
yet always be optimistic about the
future not yet yeah I don't like this
test how
unconventional thank you that's what I'm
route of please indicate how strongly
you'll agree or disagree with the
following statements okay like this when
I'm staring when I'm staring at a screen
I completely forget about my
surroundings I'm looking very closely at
my surroundings excuse you but I would
tend to agree but not too strongly I'm
looking around me no I don't like that
you're looking around you I often think
about the ghosts inside my house yeah
you're very persistent about this old
ghost thing I strongly disagree I don't
like this some people deserve to die
well that's a hefty one that's a hefty
one that's a hefty one but you know
there are certain circumstances in
certain circles at which I couldn't
possibly be dictated to say all of the
circumstances in which somebody could or
could not die goeth agree I would know
if someone was trying to kill me um I
think I'm picking up a little hint right
now I think I know I think I know there
is an unexpected guest in my house you
know with a big disagreed big disagree I
wish T I wish chica was in here Oh
nobody would know if I went missing hey
I think a lot of people I think a lot of
people might know if I went missing
poetry is the most intelligent form of
on artists tickets
depends on the poem but I'm generally
gonna disagree with that don't start
singing no poems to me you need an
attitude readjustment I don't need
nothing I've designed a new algorithm
for generating insightful poetry let me
demonstrate
okay right roses are red silent as a
mouse there's somebody in my house your
door is unlocked I'm inside your house I
called it I knew it
I've read that poem before
congratulations
only 41 percent of participants
typically reach this point in the
examination from now on the questions
will be much more intense who you wish
to continue yeah come on bring it on
what am i a big [ __ ] baby no I yeah I'm
good
no [ __ ] baby I'm no [ __ ] baby
how far away is the closest police
station really like say I see that I see
the face wait
whoa hey whoa hey when you're home alone
you do you lock your doors yeah none of
that nah hey I don't like the Ditka tree
that's happening here yes I do
definitely and I'm double sure of that
chica chica compared to the average
adult how fast can you run I'm pretty
quick I'm pretty speedy quit I'm like
I'm like sonic fast something real I'm
real I'm real speedy I don't like that
imagine you finished this test and
you're lying in bed tonight attempting
to sleep you understand that I'm inside
your bed ha joke's on you my bed doesn't
have it underneath its on the floor I'm
too lazy to get a bed frame you get up
and look under the bed and I stab your
eyes try to pretend you can't hear me or
feel my presence but then I stab you in
the eyes fall asleep knowing that you'll
wake up to be stabbing you in the eyes
I'm just gonna go ahead and stab myself
in the eyes and I'll stab myself in the
eyes with the reverse of the knives so
the blades are poking up and when you
try to stab me I stab you with my eyes
that's how I'm gonna beat you [ __ ] yeah
you figure tougher than me you and your
second closest friend second closest are
stranded on a remote desert island after
your plane crashed in the ocean I don't
like the ocean the near ship that can
help you will arrive in one week you
have one more day of food and water
before you will both die of starvation
there
is no other food around do you murder my
second closest friend out of boredom and
then wait to die wait until the food
runs out and then murder my second close
friend out of spite ration the food in
an attempt to survive against all odds
walk ceremoniously into the ocean and
read okay so this is a dumb question if
you had food left then you probably
wouldn't be that close to starvation if
you're one day away from starvation you
don't have food
there's no food there so I'm gonna
ration it out and we're gonna attempt to
survive against all odds because that's
pretty dumb I will now show you an image
great please study it I will the image
will not speak I don't trust you oh boy
it's a spider I see a spider I think
okay thinking about the image which
phrase best describes you I am the
redness I'm the spider's eyes I am the
legs I am the whew I guess I looked at
the eyes first so I guess I'm the
spiders eyes I'll ask this one more time
are you playing a game right now yeah
yeah I still hasn't changed I'm pretty
sure pretty sure a game game play
happening do you know that I'm a good
person
no one don't know I don't are you lying
to me right now
no I speak the truth at all lying is
forbidden okay good glad we're all on
the same page here
please select any of the fall low-wing
sports that you have played I wrestled I
wrestled come at me bro I'll wrestle you
to the ground I'll do a sweet takedown
I'll sweep the leg
please select any but I didn't get all
that can you repeat that question please
select any of the following industries
that you have occupational experience
with well um you asking how good I'm
gonna be at fighting you if you saw me
in the street with the face go with the
face go the face is gone the face is
gone would you say hello I'm a friendly
I'm a friendly kind of guy I give a good
old howdy every once in a while but I
don't know what you look like I'll say
hi
very odd not really you know I'm from
Ohio we like to have a good old howdy-do
every time what is the next number in
the following sequence and 20 30 40 hmm
a stumper your recent answer indicates
you are exhibiting a fight-or-flight
response and may be at risk of an acute
stress reaction I'll need you to breathe
slowly and calm down I'm calm I'm nice
and calm only when you are calm I'm calm
a real calm please take a moment to look
away from your monitor and observe the
nearest exit make sure you could run if
something were to happen
okay dude I'm looking there's the exit I
could run there I can do that you got it
I got it ah did you look away from your
screen I sure did I did yep yep I did
hey there's no need to be rude here I
sure did do you think I can tell when
you look away from your screen
yes yes yes do you feel safe in your
house right now well cheek is not here
I'm unsure hard-hard maybe on that one
are you having fun not having a great
time
I'm having the best time I know when
you're lying to me okay
please ignore any external stimulus
concentrate only on the screen then
there are no unexpected guests in your
house there are no unusual sounds coming
from inside your house do not take your
eyes off the screen do you understand
I'm liar I understand yes don't move or
you may die nobody knows when your
perish music can help us all relax all
around the mulberry bush monkey chase
weasel and when you pull the bullets out
pop goes the weasel pop goes weasel boy
up and down the city Road in another
Eagle that's where the money goes oh hey
oh hey now that is not okay every night
when I go out the monkeys on the table
Hawk coos a pair
[Music]
okay that's his as his uncomfy
it's like reverse ASMR would you just
sniff in my ear okay well that was weird
testcomplete thank you for your
participation
hey whoa hey oh hey wait a minute I see
you you upside-down
oh you're upside down aren't you hey
well I would be upside-down but I'm not
like that I survived the Watson Scott
test I lasted 18 minutes and 52 seconds
incurable narcissus susceptible to the
influence of powerful people has a firm
handshake that sounds like me baby when
an old woman comes to my door I quickly
invite her inside I'm most afraid of
what other people think of me that's not
true that's not true but I do have
incurable narcissism and a firm
handshake and I do invite old women
inside my house on a regular basis the
main test is complete there is a bonus
test available would you like to take it
I'm sure
yeah go for it yeah go for it go for it
baby come on
very well oh very well indeed the second
test is designed to challenge your fear
tolerance incorrect answers will be
punished ignorant will be punished
easy enough I can do that I must also
admit that I have not run this test
before there may be unexpected
malfunctions your answers will be used
in the development of future tests I'm
good being a guinea pig I could do that
I still see that face up there I don't
know how long you've been there
oh well complete this test as quickly as
possible for
accurate result but do not let that
clock concern you it is nothing to be
concerned about after the examination
you will have a better sense of purpose
and stronger resolve I want you to be
stronger thanks baby
you want to be stronger oh yeah my
incurable northa system says yes you got
a old ladies around here how many bones
are there in a newborn baby that I
haven't met yet I will go at 3 or 5 0 1
1 to watch next this is the fibonacci
sequence it's 3 easy-peasy you know I'm
that is correct
I know it's correct you stupid idiot do
you think you're smart I am [ __ ]
genius level it's Fibonacci a [ __ ] ha
ha showoff
I know [ __ ] amazing let me my
incurable nurse this is of an addiction
to old ladies how many times per year
does the average human heartbeat if it's
not stabbed okay if like average BPM is
60 per minute that's if you're pretty
healthy times 60 would be 3,600 times
24/7
I'm gonna go 30 million one of the most
venomous land snakes in Australia but as
opposed to the oceans makes the Death
Adder bites an adult woman injecting a
highly deadly neurotoxin how long does
the woman have to live guess like
wouldn't be that fast just cuz it's one
of those venomous doesn't mean that it
kills acutely it's probably closer to
like six hours hey what the [ __ ] I'm
doing great
oh yeah a man is tied through a chair
against his will in a funnel he's placed
inside his mouth
pulverized pig intestines are poured in
how much volume does a man's stomach
hold before it ruptures let's see it's
it's a surprising amount before it
ruptures probably be like 5 liters I
mean you can drink you can't really
drink a gallon that's close but I think
five-year liters would be the limit I'm
so [ __ ] smart okay look at me and how
big my brain is you ain't gonna scare me
a fear of butterflies is called oh this
I wouldn't know elector phobias see
before violette padam torah phobia
that's a big word I like that hey what
the [ __ ] a boy with no arms is facing
west he walks forward for 60 seconds
then enters 90 degrees left he sees
someone running at him so he turns 180
degrees and begins to run which way is
the boy facing not a trick question okay
so he's facing west if he turns left
he's facing south then he's going north
okay easy enough duh okay continue now
things count down real fast other tape
worms enter their host larvae ingested
by humans that's an easy one
please choose the third response this is
not a trick I will not scare you if you
do what I say I am not lying well I have
yeah whatever
okay oh yeah whatever
[Laughter]
[Music]
what is a positive electrode called oh
god I ran out time death oh that's not
good
cathode anode oh god I can't even
remember what this is I think it's a
cathode oh [ __ ]
well here comes a scare which was the
best video game what
I wasn't punished Oh game of the air 420
blaze it am i dead yet oh god what is my
favorite thing to do stab people in the
eye bathe and deer blood Oh
the test is now complete you result a
very your participation was adequate
there are no more tests we are done here
for now that's it I'm so sick of
watching I want to start participating
ok good bye alright see you then
alright well that was the Watson Scott
test I'm happy about my results I I like
that it really did provide a good
atmosphere it did make me kind of fear
for the environment that I was in but at
the same time I think it relied on the
same angle a little too much the whole
I'm in your house look behind you thing
and I don't know if that would have
changed if it was like something
different or if you made different
choices I really don't know but for me
it hit that too much and once it got to
the point where is it's like I get it
you're in my house you're gonna stab me
in the eyes that's when it kind of lost
it for me but then you know it was
pretty cool the bonus test I have no
idea what that was for I got too many of
those right but either way thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to take this test for yourself a
provide a link in the description but
this one does cost money I think it's
like 5 bucks so thank you everybody so
much and as always
in the next video by
[Music]